other tactics are about simply
destroying and burning the nearest
houses during the occupation it was like
this they meet someone on the street you
have a brief conversation and you run
back to your basement how long was the
city under occupation from June 5th to
September 12th it was horrifying really
horrifying one or two houses were
burning every day I was baking bread for
three families we were getting water
from the well
people lost 10 to 20 kilograms of their
normal weight in four months
potatoes
was a tourist destination
when we came here on an expedition back
in 2017 or 2018. we were Amazed by the
number of hotels various Services
restaurants and so on
has changed how the city resisted the
Russian occupation and how it lived
under occupation for more than three
months
set up a heroic resistance with small
forces
it was a small territorial defense unit
we are going to interview a member of
this unit basically one of its
organizers
as well as talk to some volunteers
we're planning to film
the head of the local Administration in
Seattle he is a highly patriotic person
in the Seattle
he joined the ranks of the Ukrainian
armed forces in 2014 and today he
actually manages the city and we also
want to talk to Roman who comes from
but it's been living in for the past 10
years
now he's back to the city and together
with the world Central Kitchen he's
feeding people cooking above 500 meals
daily
[Music]
massage
City Center yesterday we were driving by
but it was too dark
I think there's a pizzeria on the left
and we saw a single car with a light on
and approached romance
for the past several years
and he is also actively volunteering
we'll now go there and see how this
process works and how people get food
now
foreign
[Music]
for some sandwiches and we'll be feeding
the locals today
[Music]
now we're driving through the city here
we have a distribution point for
humanitarian Aid a little further you
can see that post office they've resumed
their work and installed an ATM here so
that people can withdraw cash
the city is slowly recovering
during the occupation I wasn't here but
I heard from the stories that life here
was like this you meet somebody on the
street have a brief conversation and run
back to your basement
it went like that in a loop everyone was
hiding in their places
it was scary but now it's much better
the bakery started working
fresh bread every day
now let's go pick it up
[Music]
how did this work come together
the military Administration cooperates
with volunteers
there was an offer to open a food center
for the locals
I responded to this offer and now we're
working on it how many people do you
manage to feed now we started with
cooking 220 portions that was a week ago
yesterday we already had 485 we've got
500 to 600 portions planned for the day
is this the entire population that
remains in the city now yes this is
almost the entire population
when our Ukrainian Administration came
back here they conducted a census
approximately 500 or so people are left
in the city and that's how we count on
to cook for how do you deliver products
what does this process look like
the process well we have a center a
point for cooking and distributing hot
lunches operating from from 12 to 3 P.M
after 3 P.M I drive around the city
there are assigned places where I arrive
at a certain time and hand out hot
lunches to people
this mainly concerns the uh the
neighborhoods of shevchenko Street and
the sakayun City District which which
are the most affected and destroyed
areas
are there any people who see no problem
with the fact that Russians were here
[Music]
but they don't say it openly some have a
latent attitude it doesn't matter who's
in charge as long as there's peace still
they gravitate more towards the
pro-russian opinion but they don't stick
out now
foreign
Banks were damaged people can receive
money at the post office without waiting
in line
there's one shop near the bread factory
which offers bread today during the
occupation for two weeks only two people
were baking bread at home it was very
very difficult during the occupation
they were selling every day
morning and night one or two houses were
burning every day
many people I know died my classmate
a shell got there and they died my
neighbor Alexey whom we buried a pea
teacher tokarenko whose wife buried him
in the yard having to dig a grave
herself
foreign
I collected the fragments that hit my
left leg on the table can you imagine I
went out of the house and these pieces
were there and a lot of people got
chilled it was scary to walk in the
forest they warned us not to and I
couldn't fence at the cemetery as it was
mine
many areas are being demined now but
life is still extremely tough
nevertheless the authorities promised
that everything will be fine everything
will be restored everything will be
rebuilt we hope for this and we thank
our Defenders who protect us
they say the winter will be long and
cold
it's okay you have to survive everything
I recall the story of my parents who
lived through World War II for three
years it was hard they were starving and
freezing
so we're gonna be all right we have food
thank God people help each other
not a single person said their life had
been terrible before it was so lovely
everything was fun we lived as one
family
look now it's all destroyed
such a petty
my name is
I'm 76 years old I'm a teacher of
Ukrainian language and literature for
over 54 years I worked in three schools
and taught children to love the
Ukrainian language
beautiful words were written in my
classroom my native language my native
word whoever forgets you does not have a
heart but a stone in its place
there was no electricity since the 26th
of May
and there was no water either
the water supply was over later
well we had to survive
this is where I worked in the sanatorium
not in this building but in the next one
there's not a single window left
everything was shattered and ruined
if God Wills or will be restored and
then we'll get back to our work in our
sanatorium
internally displaced persons have been
living there since 2014. they arrived
here from Don Yates
and when the full-scale war started they
were taken abroad
in Santa Romania some to the Baltic
states
and yet again they were left with just
two bags it's terrible so sorry for them
never the last day of life
we left the city in the middle of May
and two weeks later the bridge was
destroyed
our army retreated the branch was blown
up
scary really scary
oh
that's all right everything will be
Ukraine
hello hello
yes yes
repeat that
what are you talking about now the
generators
one has already been unloaded and the
other one is unloaded now
yeah yeah currently in uh
but the crane and Logistics suck yes
this is the thing now it's being
unloaded and we'll be free soon
are you from here you're local right yes
from Seattle how did the full scale
Invasion begin for you in 2014 are we
talking about 2014 or the events of
February about the events of February
about the full scale
February 24th Ed
4 40 a.m there were explosions since 50
years felt the breath of War
after Putin held a meeting with the
security Council on February 21st
if I'm not wrong
it was clear to me personally what would
happen
is
and it became evident that we will face
a full-scale Invasion but it was a
matter of when they chose the fascist
method
at four in the morning Putin declared
war and that's how the story began
Seattle here woke up at 4 40 in the
morning already at five in the morning I
was at the gas station the road map of
the war was clear and understandable to
me because in 2014 I joined the ranks in
the anti-terrorist operations Zone in
the East within the fifth wave of
mobilization
the road map was developed and ready
full tank of petrol an understanding of
where my family would be while I was
engaged in warfares and what to do next
is there a group of brothers in arms a
network of close friends with whom you
can do something
five in the morning on February 24th
we met 60 of the Personnel of the
territorial defense
then we entered this sector and in fact
for 100 days we were defending the city
of Seattle
and the surrounding territories
on the 2nd of June
we went to the other side of the bridge
to the Village
and then another story began the bridge
was indeed blown up right the bridge was
blown up on the 4th of June and the city
was occupied the next day
into a city center where we were moving
through now and further on there is the
area of the so-called
sakhalin is a suburb of further the
Luman Community Begins the town of is
three kilometers long and three wide you
can go around the city in half an hour
as it is very common what happened in
the Second City District where we are
going to now the assault in the city of
began at
all started on the first day around six
in the morning the occupying Russian
troops began an assault from the side of
the village
which is about 10 kilometers from here
they went to storm yarova yereva belongs
to the Luman Community but it is eight
kilometers from Seattle at approximately
11 30 in the afternoon they were already
at the Seattle's border yarova was de
facto no longer ours then the assault on
Villages began
around the first day all the Armed
Forces of Ukraine were clustered in the
city of
step by step they began to move to the
other side to the other side of the
bridge and take up positions directly on
the mountains
in fact Russians never managed to take
the mountains that's impossible we all
knew that it would be unrealistic you
can't come with resources they had and
cross the river
I was hoping they wouldn't enter the
city because it made no sense at all
like trying to capture towns just for
the sake of Crossing them out on the map
they paid such a high price with human
lives although
it is hard to call them human beings
they're just monsters
locusts that destroy everything
civilized and Alive by devouring
everything
the scale of Destruction here is greater
than even in kupiansk
I
it appears logical because there were
assaults here
the offenses started on the first day
you can look at the enemy vehicles
they enter populated areas with armored
vehicles and simply hid behind houses
trying to strike the Ukrainian positions
on mountains
high-rise buildings are of great
importance so they were all destroyed
what you see is just a battlefield you
don't need to be a great military expert
to understand than if you are in the
valley you will not be able to fight
against the mountain
you cannot capture such an elevated
place
is there a count of how many Russian
soldiers were eliminated here actually
no
you can make some guesses based on their
vehicle number
one infantry fighting vehicle or armored
personnel carrier
includes approximately 10 to 15 people
who may have been there that's it
that means losses losses and losses I
don't think they count their soldiers at
all or it doesn't matter to them
they just invade the territory with
corpses like in World War II and that's
it
they have significant human resources
and they bury them they knew their
tactics we knew their tactics we started
defensive operations from The borava
Village
at the beginning of May I simply lined
up three or four tanks in front of the
settlement and went on an assault
shooting the nearest houses
began to burn black smoke arose
and the wind blew and covered the
villages
in such a way the air reconnaissance
could not coordinate the actions of the
artillery
we are now entering the Luman Community
ends here the smoke was Rising covering
the settlement completely an artillery
could not see where to fire
all of their tactics are simply about
destroying and burning the nearest
houses regardless of whether there are
civilians there that's how they marched
that's how they entered
[Music]
this is
we took off the theater here city road
sign here in the spring
the plant was not operating that's it
that's the end of the city Blue Moon
community and eurova begin there
from this place the assault on Saturday
here started you can see that the bm30
smirch did not detonate this mrl missile
there's a lot of ammunition and there
will still be a lot of explosives on the
territory of sveta here's Community
Theater here stands for both the city as
the administrative Center
and the Seattle here's Community 12 more
Villages and there are Villages which
were also under occupation
some Villages were in the line of fire
for a long time and were completely
destroyed not a single house is left in
and not a single house is left in dolin
that's also the aftermath of the Russian
invasion and it concerns the sithahirs
community some settlements such as
are located along the siverski donets
river they became defensive
fortifications where the Ukrainian Armed
Forces prevented Russians from crossing
the river these settlements also
suffered great destruction everyone who
saw at the beginning of the full-scale
war people used to say bucha in European
were utterly destroyed cities but you
can see with your own eyes what yes
absolutely the city that met the war
where actual assaults took place looks
like it is incomparable regarding the
Liberation it was a very gentle
Liberation because the boys crossed the
river on boats and accumulated their
strength and no one on the riverbank
knew about it
it was an operation that our army knew
about but kept secret
and then they entered Seattle on foot
without the support of vehicles without
anything just automatic weapons
for you to understand that the
Alexandria and
are about 20 kilometers from here
and there were armored groups of the
enemy had they known they could have
gone and somehow prevent this
counter-attack
nonetheless you see
they were both afraid and did not
understand what was happening
so our boys entered very quickly
um I'll show you the tank that fought
against them an old lady
two or three men at a time transporting
the soldier there was one unit of the
Armed Forces and the National Guard and
several people from the territol defense
this was a counter-attack which led to
the deoccupation of the city of Scottish
it was Consolidated with the other let's
just appear you can drive up and have a
look well here is a tank you saw the
tank but here is what they fought
they went in just drove into the yard
and destroyed the old lady's house let's
stop here for a second
yeah okay have you seen anything like
that no
a Russian tank that's where I was hiding
and firing at the mountain
and here is its turret and here the old
lady picking the potatoes
this is the war
in this area one can identify how they
hit the vehicles they tried to advance
for about five days roughly from June
5th to 12th and then they changed their
minds and came up with hiding in the
woods and controlling the city however
in fact there are flags there I will
show you now it is essential
these Ukrainian flags were hanging there
throughout the occupation meaning
they were there for four months and no
one removed them
Russians were afraid to remove them
because they could not approach there
this side was under constant Fire
Control of the Armed Forces of Ukraine
people you see are slowly coming back to
repair their buildings
yesterday we spent the night in a hotel
the owners are trying to restore
and what is it called
oh this is not the only Hotel case
was one of the best hotels in peacetime
they preserved their premises now they
also hope to celebrate the New Year
somehow
and ran out their rooms for people
people are fighting for their existence
and businesses are fighting for their
existence
has always been a tourist Mecca
of donuts region
in fact both nature
and the Eco resource are unique here
I think you saw it with your own eyes
yes I was here before the occupation
very few people know that in gunas
region there is such a city as Seattle
which has lakes a river it's
microclimate and mountains
a unique environment what was happening
to lovra well nothing happened as it was
under Ukrainian control and the Russians
were striving to get there to set foot
on this land however they did not
succeed I suppose one of their aims was
actually not Scottish
nevertheless they failed
we were regularly visiting
as a military Administration we were
helping people carried out the logistics
of humanitarian Aid and constantly
organized evacuation from there
therefore the lover was on the side of
controlled by Ukraine
is it true that some monks of the Moscow
patriarchy swam across the river and
reunited with the Russian World I don't
have information about that
actually there is information that
people who were in the lava excuse me
they crossed the river and went to
Russia at their own risk
these flags let's drive by so you can
see two years ago in 2022 activists
including myself
and hung these flags
we ordered the holders for them and
screwed them into the lampposts our
independence day we hung them up showing
the former pro-russian mayor that's
Ukraine and thus these flags remained
hanging both during occupation and after
deoccupation these are great Flags
because they have a story behind them
these Russian monsters were here for
four months
but they couldn't do anything you see
they probably shot at them or did
something else but they never dared to
remove them
there are no Russian Flags here I am
very and there are so many of them here
there are indeed many of them yes we
thought that when we returned to the
city we would see Russian Flags instead
of these flags and yet now you see the
Ukrainian Flags remained Russians were
never able to remove them
they should have never come here of
course they looted everything destroyed
the infrastructure and ruined the city
but what did they achieve nothing
and they paid for it with the loss of
inhuman lives that's it
were there many collaborators in Seattle
if you're talking about people who have
yet to understand what was happening
there are many of them we can hardly
call them collaborators though
collaborators are people who took some
active action supporting some idea right
and if people as you say see no value
for them statehood is not a primary
value
and they grow up or were educated during
the Soviet era
fact we mostly have elderly people left
young people and middle class left in
the first days of the Russian military
aggression
they were staying abroad or in a
territory controlled by Ukraine
you won't teach people anything in a
year in 10 or 20 years
you won't achieve any results
shouldn't they have learned what Russia
is after almost four months of
occupation
it's one story when you see it on TV but
when they loot here
you know that's an interesting point I
think you should talk to the locals and
get feedback from them we communicate
actively it would be fair and you will
see everything yourself and to what
extent make conclusions from this
situation or who did not we have been
keeping an eye on the city while it was
occupied constantly monitoring what was
happening we saw our compatriots and
town people and Russian channels they
have been giving interviews rejoicing
applauding and saying Russia is cool
now we are watching them as well they're
now saying Ukraine is cool uh what can
you talk about uh
should such people be considered a
collaborator I don't know
now whoever comes they will say it's
cool and that's it we're we talk about
people who have not yet understood a
state and a person with an estate means
this is an educational Gap I guess
collaborator former head volodimir
bandura was hiding in this hotel Russian
soldiers found him when they injured the
city
took the side of Russia
back in may he used to call the Russians
occupiers the price of Truth is now
revealed bandura retained his position
and now he will head the administration
of the city for the occupiers
he is now somewhere with them in Russia
whining I don't know what he will make
of it there but what number of people
ran away with the occupiers to Russia
small percentage these are some people
that as you say were collaborators these
people accepted the idea of the Russian
World and took the responsibility of
being the administrators one Russian
soldiers came there
therefore no doubt they fled together
with the Russian soldiers I guess they
have left Ukraine and the city forever
and will never return you say they
accepted the idea of the Russian World
do you understand what the idea is
murder barbarism it's just the Russia
World key concept or something else look
if we're talking about this I put the
idea of the Russian World in quotation
marks what I mean by that is what is
provided to Russians in the mass media
however the idea of the Russian world is
I am sure to destroy everything the
whole civilization to devour it
it's a locust swarm actually we saw it
all the situations wherever they are and
somehow connected with toilets and
they're monsters what did they set up in
four months in the city of satakis
nothing but Street trade twice a week
they brought some products and those
were local entrepreneurs who stayed here
they went to a SWAT of a and brought
alcohol and cigarettes for people to
drink and smoke
that's the entire idea that's it nothing
more oh yeah the occupiers have also
been withdrawing the pension payments
from cards and charging a 30 fee while
that's the Russian World nightmare it
has been going on for four months I
could tell you that people lost 10 to 20
kilograms of the normal weight in four
months what is here to say now you can
see with your own eyes what Ukraine has
done in a month and a half we got oh
shut bang branches operating we've got
mobile Communications pension payments
Postal Service we have entrepreneurs
returning and the bakery is set up and
running you can see the difference
between what a state is and what a
quasi-republic is
that's what it looks like that's how the
Armed Forces of Ukraine and the Russians
have been watching each other for four
months hello yeah
okay
[Music]
how was the undermining of this bridge
happening
the bridge was mined back in March and
it was under control it was under
control because the assault started from
Zoom the city of a zoom and uh Village
basically everyone expected the Russian
troops could reach Seattle along the
donets river and take this Bridge Under
Fire Control
this bridge would help them move to the
other side to continue their offensive
and capture slovian's chroma tourists
and go further in Damascus region
therefore this bridge was mined back in
March
and on June 4th it was blown up
the enemies couldn't even get here
you can see why
how can you reach here
anyone appears too exposed here
and everyone who showed up was
immediately destroyed and that's it tell
me more about this action when the
Ukrainian soldiers hung the flag on the
Autumn Monument that was back in it took
place if I'm right on August 22nd not on
national flag day this was a battalion
of National Guard I won't say which
exactly they proved that so here is
Ukraine and once again reminded everyone
before the national flag day that
Ukraine is invincible and has a spirit
and on September 12th Liberation day
everyone saw it with their own eyes
while we were here we kept telling
people yes we may have to go over to the
other side maybe under enemy pressure
the Russians did have an advantage in
troops and artillery at the time but we
knew that we would come back and here we
are back I think that Victory will come
soon and everything will be fine we will
return our territories all together
Crimea Don ask region and lahon's region
and we will continue to live and rebuild
our state
was a very crucial Target for the um for
the Russian Invaders it was um it was a
place of power and
um I believe they really wanted to
capture the lavra but they failed
it's very symbolic and it once again
emphasizes our invincibility
clearly the city suffered a lot from The
Invasion and um people experienced this
period in many different ways
um admittedly I was impressed that on
the first try we were able to establish
contact with people on the street who
helped us settle in and organized our
accommodations
as you can see we're not spending the
night in the car
yes we were driving on the road to
sphere to Hurst and there was one car
with a light on we stopped
Sally our producer asked if there was a
place to spend the night and here we are
unfortunately we didn't get to the monks
but that's not bad either
yes
we were considering what was the worst
option spending a night in a car or the
Moscow patriarchate
prevented us from both and uh in
contrast we have warm even hot tea we
have mushrooms we have awesome salty
pickled apples salad sweets and a very
warm welcome
yes there is even electricity in hot
water very cool people welcomed us
we spent a lot of time inside the hirisk
we were lucky to talk to local
volunteers who cook hot meals for the
locals every day in the field
and this is truly encouraging because
people live in such harsh conditions and
still think about others
they care about their people
today I have an aftertaste of care and
love because I feel that our people have
much of it
uh I used to live in Indonesia
and I always wondered why people
continue to live in the most seismically
active areas of the world
volcanic eruptions and earthquakes are
frequently occurring there there are
several hundreds of millions of people
more than the entire population of
Russia living in these regions
basically minefields that are constantly
exploding and this cannot be controlled
in any way it's just nature taking its
course and people simply choose to live
in these minefields
we have a very similar story now
all such cities as Viet which are
destroyed to the ground it really looks
like some kind of attack of locusts that
just flew through the city and you see
so many luxury hotels that used to
welcome guests but now they are in ruins
it will be more more expensive to
restore them than to Simply build new
ones but it's cool that people are
coming back
there are not many yet but some
entrepreneurs have returned and they are
trying to reconstruct something
some people are planning to spend New
Year's Eve there and accommodate guests
and that's super cool and that's what
it's indeed inspiring
I think that we should now be looking at
countries where natural disasters happen
on a regular basis our disaster is not
natural but man-made
because our neighbor country is
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]